I have sort of what is delightful news
for you today even though in practice I
don't I don't believe it's really gonna
be a big deal a federal judge has ruled
that Donald Trump's lawyer Don McGann
must testify to house impeachment
investigators now I'll tell you the
three reasons that this is tremendous
and then I'll tell you the one reason
why it may not even matter in the end so
first of all number one what don McGann
knows and what he could say would be
explosive and it could single-handedly
change the trajectory of Donald Trump's
presidency that's reason number one why
this is a big deal
number two the Trump administration
ordered Don McGann not to cooperate to
ignore subpoenas to ignore requests and
forcing him to show up would really
anger Trump and it would throw him
completely into a whole new rage that
would be really interesting to watch and
judge Keaton G Brown Jackson said in her
decision quote no one is above the law
and that is what it would mean for Don
Magan to simply ignore legal
constitutionally enshrined subpoenas
from the House of House of
Representatives a lawyer firm again said
his client will obey the court's ruling
to testify but there are a lot of ifs
ands and buts in there by the way again
Don McGann's lawyer Magga
it's not make America great again as
I've said reports making attorneys get
attorneys Trump lawyer Michael Cohen
really needed a lawyer a trump lawyer
Rudy Giuliani as I told you recently
hired three lawyers Trump lawyer Don
Magan now speaking publicly through his
lawyer Trump makes a lot of attorneys
get attorneys the third reason that this
decision is huge is that it could impact
or signal what will happen with other
witnesses like Donald Trump's former
national security adviser John Bolton
who so far has refused to testify until
a federal court weighs in
Mick Mulvaney is another example
although make Mulvaney's attorney
attorney saying that his ultimate
decision to testify or not - will not
hinge upon what's happening here with
don McGann we'll see about that
so now let's back it up number one there
no doubt that Don McGann knows a lot of
very incriminating things about Donald
Trump the question is number one how
much of it relates to Ukraine versus
other things since the impeachment
hearings are narrowly focused on the
Ukraine Fiasco and number two don McGann
can show up and tell us nothing okay Don
McGann can show up and invoke his Fifth
Amendment right
more likely can invoke executive
privilege which is I mean I would even
say he could invoke attorney-client
privilege but it's executive privilege
is a higher level of privilege that can
be invoked so for now we don't know if
and when Don McGann might be scheduled
to testify of course the Supreme Court
could issue a stay and that stay could
last a long time certainly through the
election and even if he does show up
I would I would bet that he would assert
executive privilege so if you ask me
today we have this decision will Don
McGann ever testify I actually don't
know there are a number of scenarios
under which this will never see the
light of day and sadly once again this
is becoming an issue of checks and
balances separation of powers and
whether a determined administration an
administration determined to ignore
legal constitutionally enshrined
subpoena powers and investigatory powers
will it ultimately go ignored either via
stalling or just not paying attention
and quite frankly this attitude of so
what if we don't has worked pretty damn
well for them so far because that's how
it's gone with everything Trump talking
to Muller know I'll answer questions in
writing and be deceptive and still
Moeller is not going to go forward with
anything that is going to have a
consequence for Donald Trump Rudy
Giuliani to provide documents to
Congress and now I'm just not gonna do
it Donald Trump's tax returns now just
not gonna do it and even if a court says
it we're not going to do it and we'll
see if ultimately Trump gets away with
that that's working its way through the
system right now so the right decision
by the judge we will see if anything
comes of it we will see if McGee
shows up if he simply pleads executive
privilege invokes executive privilege
anyway I think the answer is probably
yes I want to hear from you let me know
on Twitter at D Pakman what do you think
will we ever hear from Don McGann and
remember we've got just a few days until
we do our Black Friday membership
special don't go buy cheap plastic goods
that will end up in the trash okay
that's not what Black Friday should be
about it should be about voting your
values with your dollars supporting
independent media among other things and
family of course get on our newsletter
at david pakman.com and then on friday
you'll get an email with a one-time use
coupon code that you can use to get a
just net it's an ungodly obscene
discount off of a david pakman show
membership